all right beautiful day here in Malibu
Canyon what are we doing today well I'm
going to be dropping by Franco bikes
take delivery of my new Falcon road bike
the custom paint can't wait to check it
out I've been waiting a long time for
this bike so step up my game today we're
going to go see Hector and in and check
out Franco HQ see the new
Ste get a little
fit and uh comp with my uh my boys my
new bike sponsor Franco this guy's been
been doing a great job supporting me and
I want to uh introduce you guys to him
so come along with me and uh it's going
to be a fun
[Music]
time
my
[Music]
bik guys all this
stuff yet to be some oh
[Music]
nice
there you
[Music]
go all right so we threw the uh Steed up
on the scale this is what just we're
looking at 15 14 let's play here you're
at 91 so it's it's hair long to the
bars was here oh yeah yeah but like so
this feels stretch but from uh a road
fit it's a perfect middle of the road
road fit so it's actually not bad I
actually wouldn't even change anything
so yeah I mean this is all I wanted was
to confirm the measurements I'll take
the saddle height and then we'll finish
up the fit on the new
[Music]
bik
stand up
all right Friday
morning spring break little overcast
looking at five
hours new frco spe
[Music]
today
yeah
[Music]
Malibu
criminal I just ran into on the road
criminal for sure make citiz citizens
arrest
yo
[Music]
all
right just
finished 5 hours 5 half hard hours on
the new
bike and uh I got to say it's pretty
awesome beautiful day and uh I just
can't believe the
difference in bike
this bike feels so much better I can't
wait to uh upload my ride my data so I
can kind of uh break it down and look at
um past performances cuz I was rocking
it out there today it felt good and uh I
just can't believe how swift it is
responsive how quickly it climbs so uh
good day very
happy so thanks boys and uh see you out
on the road